Booburn Mitsuo Nakatani Nakatani
Co., Ltd. It's been 23 years.
Dai
Live 0
It's also a traditional culture.
Well, when you're happy, mochi is really sticky, isn't it
? Delicious mochi is soft and stretches well.
There is rice called glutinous rice that grows well.
I have this glutinous rice.
Well, it will arrive firmly and quickly in about 2 minutes
.
Well, in some areas,
rice cakes are made early.
Well, there are various characters with rice cakes, but in
general, one person is attached from the beginning and one person
kneads.  There is no practice called practice.
Well, it was said that it was twisted three times a second.
This is the bone of foreign capital. This is only the
timing.
After all, I'll do that while calling
out. It's a small thing. It's a
true ball game
. Mochitsuki 9 is right. Anyone can do it.
Anyone can do it if
they have the
motivation.  I think that the face when I ate rice cake has a unique human face, but
I'm happiest to see the
others
.